[Music]
I'm an only child
I had a great childhood I have two
amazing parents that gave me everything
I needed
I thought I could fly when I was young
I mean we were poor but
it was so much
loved it we didn't really notice
we grew up at an environment where you
never really knew what was going to
happen and
that creates a lot of uncertainty
compared to previous generations okay we
might be a bit skinned we might not be
able to afford the best pair of shoes
but we're not living in poverty
we make plenty of money like we make
plenty of money it's not like we won the
lottery and moved into a big fancy
neighborhood
[Music]
my integrity
is what I have you know a long time ago
people's word and integrity meant a lot
[Music]
I grew up happy
in the Appalachian Mountains
foreign
we had good Christmases we had love I
was normal
but now
what the hell am I now
[Music]
can you hear me
no challenge is more urgent
we can either settle for a country where
a shrinking number of people do really
well while a growing number barely get
by
or we can restore an economy where
everyone gets a fair shot and everyone
does their fair share and everyone plays
by the same set of rules
these United States are confronted with
an economic Affliction of great
proportions
it is time to reawaken this industrial
giant to get government back within its
means and to lighten our punitive tax
burdens on these principles there will
be no compromise
foreign
what's happening are you going back to
work or not
all-out War by the council workers
another industrial dispute this time the
Lorry drivers has led to some Panic
buying in the shops and markets it felt
that whatever the Government tried to do
it wasn't necessarily making things
better it might be making things worse I
did think that the free market would
produce the resources that could make
everybody better off the argument was
that if you did these things we will get
rid of unemployment there'll be more
investment there'll be more income that
will trickle down
water without big Rewards
people like me are not going to work
15 to 20 hours a day in order to get
rich
[Music]
in graduate school my doctoral years I
was told psychologists five to ten years
into practicing on average we're making
a hundred thousand dollars a year and I
was like
that sounds awful
that was like kind of like my incentive
to be like the top one percent
I'm not in the top one percent in terms
of the world it's maybe in just the
psychology world
I choose this I choose to drive I could
take a train in directly into the city
to just feel like that's one extra time
that I could get sick being in an
enclosed area with lots of strange you
know in the public it's like I don't I
can't afford to be sick at this point in
my career I every day counts while I'm
trying to save this house
foreign
get my coffee with espresso shot in it
my red eye
and I walked directly to my office
usually here five minutes to 11.
and turn on the lights here sit down and
I go bang bang bang one session after
the next it's non-stop it's not like I
leave I can't leave this little box of
an office I don't have anyone to talk to
like I never need to leave the building
other than to get lunch which I pray to
do every once in a while to get to sit
alone at a counter at a diner across the
street and that to me reading the New
York Post is heaven
foreign
[Music]
thank you
there you go
my day starts on Sunday
and doesn't end until the following
Friday
because once Monday here I'm up Eddie
Eddie just like this
it's a constant battle everything
creates a little bit of stress
I'm gonna tell y'all one more time
don't come in that door no mouth
shut it down
Nah when I get in real
stress mode I might smoke about four or
five cigarettes I don't know
but
you can't drink on your job
because if that was the case I'd have a
flask at work
we have potato wedges or green beans or
sweet loose corn or macaroni and cheese
okay um there's something you said
sweet loose corn
macaroni and cheese potato wedges
or green beans okay now what I've done
it was mashed potatoes look can you make
up your mind what you want
and help you you know I'm on this end
now help me please
we're doing okay
okay I know a little slight
interruptions I know y'all bleep them
out if you can
Sunderland over one in four men are
unemployed
employees were announced last week think
of differences started widening rapidly
from the mid 80s onwards the weaker
trade unions are the more inequality
there is it's a very striking
relationship today's unemployed are the
victims of yesterday's mistakes
that's the past the government's getting
inflation down interest rates down
reforming Trade union law cutting
regulations and moving restrictions
the balance of power between employers
and employees shifted in favor of
employers I think that happened and I
think it was a deliberate result of
policy
thank you
foreign
[Music]
oh yeah
[Music]
oh it's a team for the kids
they might still be in bed when I go to
work and then when I come home the back
to bed and I know it just bores the life
of them because they can't do much
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
it's awful but you think to yourself
because you you're going to lose a lot
of hours if if you don't get something
to fill that Gap anything else I can do
farewell I'm here
tomorrow yeah I'm probably going to be a
bit late tomorrow I mean it's Saturday
the way services are commissioned out
people are seen as units for sale sold
to the lowest bidder half an hour to get
somebody up get them washed get them
dressed give them the meds
and have a meaningful conversation it
doesn't work
how long have you got for this one I'm
gonna be 20 20 25 minutes in here
people look on your own is that all you
do no no it's not all I do I'm not just
a carer I'm a carer
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
and stay away from me
[Music]
why don't you let me be
don't know why
you keep on holding me
we had went to where my husband was from
and we had decided we were
you know I'm gonna um
have our you know have our own business
and everything and and that was you know
where we started we had we had a so we
bought a video store and when Walmart
got into video business it really just
killed it for the mom and pop stores you
know we didn't have the volume of uh
what Walmart would have so
um after five years we ended up closing
it
I was in the Walmart one day and they
had a sign
um they were hiring and I thought well
you know go put an application in and
when they called I was really surprised
and I was even more surprised how good
of a company it was to work for any
extra effort you put forth they
appreciated it the managers would just
come in and say I saw what you did and
hey that you know thank you until the
changes came the focus of the company
went to cutting operational expenses
less people to do the work but yet the
same amount of work we have to go to
work soon
and I think I go at four today
3 30 today's the fourth you see every
day you're like what time do I go
to work don't you think that is just
nerve-wracking
I know
and I'm not the only one I've talked to
people across the country and they do
the same thing you know it's like what
time do I go to work
you would not believe how much stress
that puts in your life
[Music]
we are living through a moment of
absolutely astonishing transformation
all of you know that the information and
Technology explosion will offer to you
and to the young people of the future
more opportunities and challenges than
any generations of Americans has ever
seen
[Music]
it's a stock market boom not seen since
the heady years of the 1980s
Dow Jones index up by almost a quarter
in just 12 months with record profits
and million dollar bonuses appearing in
paychecks once again
it's really changed is that if you were
once the CEO of a company your company
served a local market now most markets
that are important are Global in scope
if you're the CEO of Apple computer and
you make the company three percent more
efficient than it would have been you've
added 1.2 billion dollars to the
company's bottom line your economic
value has just grown explosively we're
really pleased to report that this
quarter we earned 106 million dollars
Bill Gates of Microsoft is now worth 29
billion dollars up 10 billion got more
of Intel computers 6.7 billion Up 3
billion and Bill Hewlett of
Hewlett-Packard a personal Fortune of 4
billion up a billion all in just six
months if you end up at the top of this
process then you do have a justification
for what's happening to you the market
is an efficient way of allocating
resources it's allocated a lot of
resources to me and that me must be an
efficient result it must show that I'm
hardworking and clever and in quotes
deserve what I'm getting
very few people have
the mental resources
the energy
I mean look look at me here I am I'm
creating an African art collection I'm
creating companies
my youngest child is three I'm 70 years
old
I have four children 13 and below
so what does that say about me I mean
I'm out there creating
there are a lot of things that
perpetuate inequality economic systems
governments policy one of the things I
would argue is also psychology how
people think the kinds of things that
they value inequality is rising but
people aren't aware of what they're
doing to contribute to that
[Music]
foreign
most of the gated communities are either
on a golf course or our Golf Course
adjacent
some of the amenities are really
great really great
but for some people it really it is
about living behind a gate well I live
behind a gate and you do not live behind
a gate and look at how much better it is
that I live behind a gate
[Music]
honey
we didn't buy this house to one up our
friends who didn't buy a house behind
the gate but we had a lot of friends
that really thought we did we had
friends that were like no we won't come
and visit we won't come and see you we
won't
kind of that you moved over there we
moved over here
it's really sad
it's really sad
[Music]
in general everyone pretty much keeps to
themselves
[Music]
do you want the bananas for your
Hamburger sandwich no so
we don't know anything about our
neighbors I ain't nothing
I found another hamburger
one of the things that for a couple of
our neighbors has really bent them out
of shape is that we haven't hired a
gardener so this Neighbor comes out and
stares at me visibly pregnant raking
leaves is just staring and he yells from
across the street you know only poor
people only only poor people rate their
own leaves
how excited are you to take that Jaguar
be nice how excited are you to see the
house I'm very excited
I think this community is going to be
like more young people that are like us
so it's like I'm gonna meet a whole new
crew of young dads who are going to want
to play football and softball with me
and tennis and I feel like this is the
best community that we could ever have
wanted it has everything it has the
great School District I mean I think
we've really lucked out Greg was even
talking to someone the other day and he
was like it's like a place where there's
tennis courts there's a pool there's a
guard gate there's like you know there's
a lot of young people and he goes oh it
must be Boulder Ridge and Greco's yeah
that's it so it's like a well-known it's
like it's this is like a diamond in the
rough place this is like the best place
in Westchester that's amazing yeah
everyone bases where they live around
schools we're going to be sending our
girls to a school in Ardsley one of the
top school districts in the nation and
it's going to be a great quality of life
and a great environment with great
Future Families to meet and
and I think it's going to be funny
because I'll end up finding a lot of
Wall Street characters living there
hello
I met in these gated communities people
who just say You Know Rich I just want
my kids to attend safe schools I just
want my property values to stay stable I
just want uh the beautiful amenities of
Life private Parks private bike paths
private lakes and so they're not so
aware of the way privilege works on
their behalf what are we going to see
first okay so we're now in Boulder Ridge
we're in Boulder Ridge it's a large
community with hundreds of homes it has
a gatekeeper 24 hours a day so nobody
can enter here without it being known
who they are right that means that it's
Crime Free that's great I gonna make me
feel safe
when I go on my speeches out of town to
know that someone and the girls are
protected exactly
nice cars here
I think this is the perfect place for
you
once you reach a certain tax bracket
there's this expectation that you will
just kind of keep up whatever the
appearance of the tax bracket is
cars are a big deal
most people drive a Mercedes or BMW or
if they do drive an American car it is
the newest possible version of whatever
we drive to BMWs it's not that we have
decided to drive a 1988 Hyundai I'm very
happy with the fact that my car just
rolled 200 000 miles
it means I've taken care of something I
paid a lot of money for that's not what
you do here you buy something you use it
for like six weeks and then you get rid
of it and buy the newest version of
whatever the IT thing is
[Music]
people have always been kind of obsessed
with wanting things the car they drive
the clothes they wear
the same way you want to leave your
house looking good because people judge
you on what you look like or what you're
wearing
like
foreign
Executives athletes and entertainers
they expect a certain presentation style
so I have to keep up of certain image in
their eyes so that they respect me and
value my opinion so you know I I
definitely let my wife help me sometimes
with the
Styles brand names and stuff like that
but she seems to be very good
like getting me dressed for success
but I'm a big believer in that if you
dress well every day you actually feel
like
you're more powerful and you feel like
you're more successful and sometimes you
can like dress your way to success in
essence I've seen people get out of
depression just by just looking good
I feel like the guy that's good at all
and you become the guy that's gonna fake
it to you make it
okay
[Music]
foreign
mode of transportation when you're in
the neighborhood is a golf cart
everyone gets to kind of show off their
golf cart and they'll be golf carts with
off-road wheels and there'll be golf
carts for both kids and there will be
golf carts with kits that you plug onto
the front of it to make it look like a
Mercedes people will dump 10 20 000 into
a golf cart
most Americans are fair-minded and they
won't say I'm going to a gated community
to flee brown people most people don't
think like that they're simply saying
that
the perceived sense of safety the higher
property values that's why I'm moving to
these communities it has nothing to do
with race and so there's a divide and
that's how you segregate a community
those who aren't perceived to fit in are
not accepted people who did not golf
people who did not go to a certain
Church those types of people often felt
excluded
nope we're not gonna go no hey hands
thank you
I appreciate this very good listening
when Max was little where we lived
before there was a park at the End of
the Street
the kids would all play together and
everyone had a good time together and
all of this
you know that's not the way it is here
okay up onto the curb
okay
[Music]
there you go we at least ethnically look
like the vast majority of our
neighborhood and I still have not come
to terms with the fact that my kids are
perceived as the different ones
not too near the swings
I don't need you to get kicked in the
head today
I have perfectly normal looking blonde
head blue-eyed nice kids
and this girl ran in fear screaming
from Max
the playground just ran and she kept
screaming it at him how horrifying he
was and her mom was like yep it's okay
honey I know
something is wrong with this Dynamic if
my totally normal kid cannot make a
friend at the playground
[Music]
there has been more than one day that
I've called Ryan just in tears
like I can't take my kid to the park
[Music]
New York is booming with conspicuous
consumption very much back in fashion
the luxury car dealerships can hardly
remember a time like it do you believe
that an individual can earn too much
money what you mean that we should sort
of cap someone's income hmm not really
no why what's the point what we know has
happened is that people at the top of
the income ladder have gotten all the
income gains that have occurred during
the last 30 years people in the middle
of the income distribution they've run
down their savings they've run up much
more debt every conceivable margin you
can work just to hold your place in the
queue
[Music]
it's the perfect way to help manage your
short-term cash flow
government figures released today show a
record number of people are insolvent
if you don't pay or contact us within
seven days our collections team may
arrange for an agent to contact you and
visit your home the last day the first
and it's the ninth today
and when when does she's gonna cook
within seven days
just to go on the front of them
and it's sure how much oh yeah
my catalog bill is between three and a
half four thousand pounds but then I use
that for stuff that
you know when the kids need new coats
new shoes I've got no money left you've
got ah I've got to get it from somewhere
everything's so much more expensive and
lucino she wants a computer and you feel
so you have to do those things for them
because their friends are getting them
and they're gonna look like the odd one
out if they don't get them
another cuddle too
you've got a cut back
School are always on the phone when I've
missed the dinner money payments that
happens quite a lot
then later
people went from pretty simple Financial
lives pre-1980 to the point now where
people are
just totally submerged in their
financial accounts and they're all in
debt debt to us might seem oh you know I
need this loan to go to school or I need
this loan to buy a house but to Wall
Street it's just a product that they can
buy and sell and package and so it's
just another way for them to get as much
profit as they want and they treated as
such and they treat it like a game
hello
I'm at work right now can I call you
later but I did make the payment on the
third
all right five five four thank you man
all right you have a blessed day bye-bye
oh red third quarter
crazy
[Applause]
I owe a couple of deck companies now and
the only thing I can do is they gotta
wait in line I have to pay this for two
weeks and then pay half of the rent and
pay the late fee on that and just juggle
I gladly pay you Tuesday for a
cheeseburger today
you know but that's the way it is man
hey
yo
moves for his house called him Joe who
set up his bills there's too much we owe
we just need a loan that will last till
payday so they logged on to dollars
direct.ca dollars direct.ca is fast and
convenient just be 18 years or older
have regular employment and direct
deposit
dollars direct.ca
apply and get cash the same day
one of the things that I'm going to talk
about a little bit today is how to
create a more secure America
by achieving the goal of five and a half
million new minority homeowners
they don't want there to be a fine print
preventing people from owning their home
once Wall Street figured out that they
could create these mortgage products
they were like wow this is the deal of a
century we need to make more of these
this is always the big one
um it's the way that the economy is is
set up
buy a house housing values tend to go up
and so it's a major component of of your
retirement and so losing your house you
can find yourself in a position where
instead of being able to retire you just
might have to continue working
and you go to buy a house you're really
making a bet with hundreds of thousands
of dollars that this this place is going
to hold its value and that everything is
going to work out
houses that fall really drastically
behind the trend
um
I have a really hard time selling
and when they do sell they sell for Less
I think it would be more pressure if we
were actively looking to sell our house
today we just try to kind of keep up and
make sure that we don't
fall really far behind
hi I'm Karen Hobart hi I'm Jen I'm the
owner of Rancho Miranda homes and land
real estate it's a pleasure glad you
made it this is listed at 429 900 and
it's on a 0.25 of an acre quarter acre
lot
and they have they've done so many
upgrades it's basically a brand new home
but it was originally built in 1981.
what I like about it watch your step is
they've done all the new laminate
flooring
they did not do the windows so we have
single pane windows dual pane windows
just in this room but they put an entire
new heating and air conditioning system
that was twelve thousand dollars now I
have to show you how fantastic these
cabinets are they're they're the full
extension cabinets oh yeah and the
self-close
with the damper
Hulk up for a gas this one does have
propane it's copper lime
interesting
all the houses have a different
character in a different style
especially that one it's a nice looking
house and that one pretty the
Mediterranean
yeah it's just got a nice style to it
so this is absolutely one of the best
streets in Rancho Murieta it's
completely quiet you'll never really see
anybody going by but the people that
live here and the most expensive homes
in the neighborhood are down the street
yeah and on the lake
okay
well come on in let's see what you think
that first house has hands down has the
highest per square footage yeah I don't
feel like you're getting a lot for that
exactly by significant margins but I
feel like at least if you look in
comparison to where our home is at I
feel like we're fine if we did find
ourselves in a position where we needed
to list the house we are still we're
just fine yeah
more days than not my first patient will
probably be at 11 o'clock which means
that I would get up around eight get my
workout gear on and go for a run
I'd go running for about 45 minutes to
an hour
loving running outside
[Music]
I know I pushed myself but there's
really no option other than pushing
myself
you know your back's against the wall
when you have to make a mortgage payment
[Music]
he just had back surgery and he
literally worked the next day didn't
skip a beat had surgery Wednesday I
worked Thursday Friday went into the
office on Monday he had a sick day he
couldn't go into the office and make
money so it's important obviously that
he stays healthy for himself for a
family and for his client
the government had been collecting data
that showed there have been these huge
class differences in life expectancy
and
people didn't really believe the data
even people working in important
positions in the Health Service didn't
know whether death rates were highest at
the top or the bottom
from cooking we came into capitalistic
principle I'm trying to put my smoke
back on his face but I couldn't get it
so I said okay for goodbye to all but
one of my principles and start
converting off the floor that led me to
the slippery Road
I wasn't always this way I guess it
started on the day they called the
Cottons on the casket and she flew away
and left me here grounded cuddling on
the truth pain my biggest ambition in
life try to get through a day
my mom thought he sucks when she died if
I keep drinking that's me
imagine that being dead at 36 [ __ ]
sake
of all of the things that I need to do
to try to lengthen my life which is
already cut short because I was born in
Pollock if I make it to 70 I'll be lucky
and that's if I eat salad every day
now of course because of a growing body
of research people know that
unemployment and poverty and have health
consequences
instead of the former idea that it was
businessman stress that led to the worst
health problems
[Music]
a lot of health problems everything from
high blood pressure to AIDS to hepatitis
all different kind of diseases around
here
[Music]
and the bug ground is a good day
that's what I've been told
actually this is what I know you know if
you can live to see it
my daughter's father passed on the 23rd
of last year
so
that kind of hurt me a little bit
back to being a single mother
he died of liver cancer
yeah it was really sad
but it is it's a good thing
you know I know we're in a better place
he suffered for a while quite some time
yeah I do I do
we was together 14 years long time
in Glasgow
men living in the poorest part have a
life expectancy of 54.
in India three-quarters of the
population live on two dollars a day or
less
no one in Glasgow lives on two dollars a
day or less and yet men in the poorest
part of Glasgow have life expectancy
that's eight years shorter than the
average in India
and I thought aha that's it that's going
to explain it being relatively
disadvantaged
found
which determine High rates of suicide
violent deaths alcohol heart disease
so this is where I had my first
um
drink Outdoors
it was a Friday night we came down what
was it it was old a bottle of old
Westminster
and uh it's funny because like I ended
up developing a bit of a taste for a
certain brand of fortified wine
um
but I remember just thinking this is
disgusting why would anybody want to do
this
of course I could become addicted to
going to the gym
you know like
and become addicted to fruit
you know like phone in my sponsor
ah man I went mad I don't need bananas
earlier on my potassium fell off the
chain
oh
alcohol gave me what I thought was
confidence
so it's that core belief that you're
worth something that I am missing
it was a painkiller for your spirit
really
[Music]
everybody is trying to escape in their
own way used to trying to escape
um by doing different things like
marijuana and stuff like that
um
the age people probably drink or do
something
to escape older people probably just
don't care because they old they don't
have to deal with that so
but everybody's trying to escape
something
I use my bed my cigarettes
and give me a little beer every now and
again and that's about the size of it
look at me a good movie and go to bed
do you have a go-to when you've got a
tough day no we're actually ice cream I
like ice cream
sometimes I'll sit with a pint of that
and eat until I can't eat no more until
I'm stuffed
I think you look good with a little meat
on your bones
yeah it means you're eating good at home
[Music]
I feel very anxious all the time
and the nervousness is just even the
customers say I don't smile anymore
for example a man yesterday he told me
he said you look like you need to calm
down and I'm like I can't you know we
was like you gotta have a heart attack
and I'm like I know
[Music]
I
used to work and I would leave and I
would uh go jogging at the gym and all
this kind of stuff and everything and I
got to where instead I would rather come
home and sit down and eat instead you
know
you know I was walking out and I was
like man it's been rough because we were
so short-handed I was like I'm gonna go
just go sit in my vehicle and eat some
chips till I come down you know but you
know that's the wrong things to do
[Music]
if you take an economics course you're
taught that markets are based on
informed consumers making rational
judgments you're supposed to turn on the
television set
take a look at the ads I mean are they
trying to create informed consumers
making rational choices
contrary they're trying to create
uninformed consumers that will act
irrationally and that's a huge industry
one of the biggest industries in the
country
[Applause]
the Texas Double Whopper eat like a man
man
people around here are uh kind of big
yeah healthy that's what I like to say
pleasantly plump
[Music]
that way I'm built you call me fat
because
[Music]
oh I can't wait until Thanksgiving just
seeing that turkey
because I got a hand man a turkey in
there
but if you've really fool don't worry
about it going oh are you tired
yes I am
I have to have my daughter I had
congestive heart failure
and actually literally died
and um it took me two weeks to come out
of the coma I'm just lucky that my heart
still is
beaten long enough to do what it need to
do you know but that's just making it
weaker
all right
why did you start getting the high blood
pressure
um in 2004
can y'all shut up
shut up and shut the door
shut all the noise up
everything needs to be shut everybody
need to be sitting down and being quiet
all right period
okay back to me
[Music]
it just makes me sleep easy at night
knowing if I'm home by myself with my
kids that there's somebody watching over
us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I would love to see more of Alden I
always say I wish I had a husband that
worked a nine to five job you know where
we were able to come home together at
night and take care of the kids together
but I I know that's not reality and I
know he's providing a lifestyle for us
that without him working as hard we
couldn't have
we know that financial distress is one
of the main factors that sends people to
see marriage counselors in the areas
that saw the biggest increases in
inequality we saw the biggest increase
in divorce rates people in the middle
are trying to make ends meet and in the
process and experiencing an enormous
amount of additional stress in their
lives it's
it's what happened today
that made you laugh
okay all right good mommy kissy after a
week I'm exhausted I work all day and
then I come home to two kids to feed and
bathe and read to and kind of make up
for all the hours that I wasn't home
during the day
I love you
night night
[Music]
that's awful I feel tremendous guilt
not being able to see the girls and put
them to bed and it's very frustrating
when the girls are more used to her than
me
hey
I'm exhausted how's your day that's all
right it was fun it was there yeah okay
goodbye it was awesome
how are you I'm good
um this is a gotchi paper for all the
criminals
in the neighborhood so
um page for page
and tell you who've been arrested and
what they done did and sometimes I'll be
looking in here for my son's little
friends because I don't want none of
them to be having no future till while
I'm I'm in there cooking that's just
from people stressing out
because the economy is so jacked up over
here and that's why we end up with
situations like these people for
different felonious assaults and because
they mad and frustrated can't get a job
of breaking the animal and trying to get
into people houses or
pure
rage against another person wanting what
somebody else has
they'll just find anything to take the
frustration out on because they ain't
got too much else to do
psychologists and sociologists have
worked with violent criminals
consistently say that lack of respect is
the trigger for acts of violence and
aggression all that's left to people is
the maintenance of the self-respect and
so if that's threatened in some way then
you see these violent and aggressive
reactions
policing Bakers say two teenage boys and
a 15 year old girl
dinosaur gun fight and a birthday party
at a privately owned Club This Is Not
Unusual they've had a lot of people
killed in this little town in the past
few years high school students killing
each other you know and you know it's
you never know when you you know you're
going to be robbed and
I would love to walk to work or ride a
bike to work you know because it's only
like two miles down the road
but I'm too scared to ride a bike or
walk home at midnight I always worry
about walking out of that parking lot
always so with half the lights out right
now
you know it's a very dangerous place
last year
three times a number of
police and Community are trying to
address an epidemic of violent crime
much of it rooted in drugs street
sweeper shotgun
12 12 gauge rounds in this drum magazine
no sights because it's not designed to
need any sites
[Music]
sick of this Commonwealth I'm sick of it
I'm stressed out all this [ __ ] is just
it's just devastating look at it look at
me
thank you keep them around your neck
please
[Music]
I don't trust none no more
[Music]
you know after the store closed after it
get dark around here I'm in I don't care
what's out there I'm I'm good
this war on crime is being waged to
every level
those who can afford it are getting out
of the way retreating to gated walls and
States from where they can watch the new
Republican battle for the survival of
America
[Music]
yes we're here to visit the Grove Hogs
g-r-o-v-h-o-u-g
I Steve booth there we go
you guys having a good night so far so
far I had a good day all right thanks
sir oh you're welcome
apparently a neighbor saw it called us
Apparently one of his chickens got
mauled and another one got
nipped out and chased around
was able to was able to get it mediated
with him got him calmed down
um the coyote side yeah the coyote
siding yeah did they give you any
information about that not much just
that it was crossing the road right up
on the North side did it sound like it
was that big one sounded like it was
that big one yeah okay so maybe he's
been hanging around for a few months now
I think hasn't it I believe so
and then we'll uh the vast lake pump
house somebody tossed some rocks through
the windows up there oh okay yeah that's
a new one and there's that uh other
loose dog that we're talking about okay
I think that'll square that away and it
looks like everything's noted on the
cards properly so
that sounds good I'll grab a cup of
coffee and let you stretch your
feet out a little bit and then we'll
continue that sounds like a plan just
made some fresh stuff for you
violent crime in the fear it provokes
are crippling our society
limiting personal freedom and fraying
the ties that bind us
now Those who commit repeated violent
crimes should be told when you commit a
third violent crime you will be put away
and put away for good three strikes and
you are out
I get caught with a gram a dope 1.5
grams
okay then
I wasn't hurting anybody but myself I
wasn't selling it you know I didn't give
it to kids or anything like that
and I go to court
there wasn't trying to hear anything
they they used at three strikes law
against me and they gave me a 25-year
sentence I've been in a box just a
little bit bigger than this for the last
17 years and to be locked up and treated
as I've been treated here
there's not a man alive that wouldn't
feel the same way that I do now they've
created a ball of hating meaning
yeah I'm in the penitentiary
but you know something I've never
I've never been caught with anything
I got to get butt naked in front of
females and these officers and I gotta
bend over and show them my [ __ ]
yeah humiliating it it's beyond that
I had on I had all of my mouth
I had those kicked out on the Robertson
unit
I was beaten almost to death
they broke eight ribs they dislocated my
arms my legs they broke my jaw they
kicked out my grill they broke my ocular
bone my nose
but you know something the first time
that I did get my head ripped off three
days later it didn't hurt as bad
and then I didn't then I became a
monster
I hate people
and do you know how sad that is to say
I you know I I've been treated so bad
back here that yes I could I could
actually now I could kill a man
you know I I really could I could kill
one of these laws you know and then
that's sad that's sad because I you know
I was raised I was raised better than
that
and what am I going to do now miss round
when I get out what am I going to do get
me a job at McDonald's
I'll be 54 years old came down when I
was 26.
I was in college I was taking a votech
what am I what am I going to do now
because what you were before you come to
the penitentiary is not what you're
going to be when you're released
[Music]
this is a country that began
with the language of Liberty and yet we
have more people in prison per capita
than anybody in the world
[Music]
there's no doubt that being rich makes
it much less likely that you'll be
incarcerated even if you've done
something terrible
four ounces of solid silver and 2.2
carats of diamonds
this is the richest year ever in human
history the rich are getting richer this
is evidence on our list these are
creators they're not plutocrats these
are doers making things happen and when
they do well we all do well
there's a religion that says everyone
will benefit
there's almost nothing to do with the
real world so it completely fails in the
real world if houses the wrong word it's
not a failure for the
fraction of one percent of the
population that's accumulating wealth
you know beyond the dreams of avarice
the influence of money in politics has
risen dramatically in recent decades the
people at the top have more money what
they've been doing has been giving
bigger contributions to politicians and
in return asking for lower tax rates on
themselves and less stringent
regulations on their companies from
humble beginnings in small town Arkansas
to the world's leading retailer Walmart
has come a long way since 1962. no one
except for maybe Sam who never lost
sight of his original idea could have
predicted the company's remarkable
growth well that's an interesting case
because Walmart has produced a large
number of hereditary billionaires and
they are no doubt highly respected in
the communities in which they live and
no doubt they do respectable things they
fund museums and they give money to
hospitals and I'm sure they do all that
stuff
and yet you know in many communities
people who work at Walmart are
getting the wage but also getting food
stamps so basically the public is paying
for all months labor
for a fiscal year ending 2012 Walmart
has gross sales of like 446 billion and
then the net sales were 16.7 but almost
17 billion dollars in net profit I have
no problem when it coming making a
profit like I said I have my own
business but when you're making a profit
at the expense of the people who are
doing the work and their their own food
stamps it's a moral issue if you're
making a decision all right we're going
to cut hours so we can keep profit up
you know what you're doing
we've been finding that wealthier
individuals are more likely to perceive
the pursuit of self-interest as opposed
to Collective interest as being moral
and favorable we're even observing this
moralization of greed this greed is good
mentality this culture absolutely
selects for Psychopathic thinkers you
know people who literally have no
empathy whatsoever because once you have
successfully cleaved off ethical
considerations you're incredibly
efficient I I think there's nothing
wrong with aspiring to be comfortable I
don't even know that there's anything
wrong with aspiring to be rich but the
aspiration of Wall Street is to have
[ __ ] you money and and [ __ ] you money is
the amount of money so vast that you
could pick up the phone or say [ __ ] you
to whoever you wanted without
repercussion
one of the necessary illusions
for the general public is that we live
in a capitalist economy but the rich
don't believe that for a minute they
insist on a powerful state to protect
them from Market discipline so if
Goldman Sachs makes a risky transaction
they're basically protected if it
crashes
they can run to the nanny state with
their cap in hand and get bailed out
good morning this is a pivotal moment
for America's economy
problems that originated in the credit
markets
and first showed up in the area of
subprime mortgages
have spread throughout our financial
system it's been a dismal week on Wall
Street in the last
Five Points alone yesterday the Dow
closed down 500 investors agree that
this is a crucial week to see whether or
not the government can step in and heal
this economy I'm a strong believer in
free enterprise
under normal circumstances I believe
companies that make bad decisions should
be allowed to go out of business
but these are not normal circumstances
you know the president has said over and
over it's the people's money
he's right about that it is the people's
money but now it's the people's debt
this is a pain
that will stay with me for the rest of
my life but you got to keep 480 million
dollars
I I have a very basic question for you
is this Fair
the spectacle of these Bankers who have
contributed hugely to bringing the
Western economies to their knees and yet
are still going on paying themselves
money beyond the dreams of avarice in
most people's eyes and they really think
they're worth it and sometimes I meet
them socially and they say Max when will
you understand this is how capitalism
works I say this is not how capitalism
works this is how capitalism goes
hopelessly disastrously wrong
[Music]
[Music]
I'm the best person to speak on behalf
of the Wall Street Community because I
sit across from them
you know I see the humanity of people on
Wall Street are working harder now than
ever before
not knowing whether they could ever move
up the ladder and when will this Rat
Race end for them
[Music]
Dr Alden Cass is a clinical psychologist
and probably more than anything else
is known for helping people manage
uncertainty
and maintain optimal motivation and
performance
in times of uncertainty
Alton all right thanks
[Applause]
it's become a mission for me to help
people out during this rough time
because I feel like in my practice as a
psychologist my clients are looking to
me for answers my dissertation was the
first study in the United States
conducted in the last 50 years it was
called casualties of Wall Street an
assessment of the walking wounded and my
findings basically showed that we are
currently in a crisis of connectivity
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
pop songs
[Music]
we should not bail out those who made
The Reckless decision to buy a home they
knew they could never afford
[Music]
that word came up a lot oh greedy
homeowners
this is just about four people who
bought TVs on their second mortgages and
it's their fault and they were greedy
that's the mentality blame the victim
[Music]
I kept using my credit cards to live and
then I finally got those where I was
maxed out and I'm at the end and
I'm fixing to be moving
I've got to go very soon within the next
few weeks you know I mean
um this this is this is it
you know
there's a lot of data
suggesting that social Mobility is an
all-time low people despite their hard
work aren't achieving the American dream
so who is it that achieves wealth it's
often those individuals that are born
into wealth in the first place
[Music]
I actually feel like I'm blessed with
having everything I need could not be
luckier
could not ask for anything more right
now
slimy
[Music]
[Music]
dead 15 years old I left Big Stone Gap
Virginia and I hitchhiked across this
entire continent to Southern California
and I had a good time I was young
heterosexual
hey life was good I was thinking about
going to Hollywood
being the next Tom Cruise or somebody
you know I mean
but it didn't happen like that
my mom had heart and lung infection
and she died in 89 and it crushed me it
crushed me you know I went into a spiral
of doing wrong
spiral doing things to get by and it
took me down a long road that I didn't
want to travel but I did I was hanging
out with the wrong people doing the
wrong things
um trying to make money trying to
you know survive pretty much I went to
jail for about a year and I came out and
still couldn't get it straight then I
had kids and and at that time I couldn't
have them with me because I was so
wiped out but after my congestive heart
failure I woke up it was a wake-up call
that I needed
it was a solely needed wake up call and
I did that
so I've been Off to the Races ever since
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
school is a great place for kids
who are even slightly above the Curve
so we'll probably homeschool but if
they're not staying on track meeting the
Milestones meeting the goals that they
need to meet it's going to impact
long term what their outcome looks like
no challenge is more urgent
no debate is more important
we can either settle for a country where
a shrinking number of people do really
well while a growing number of Americans
barely get by
or we can restore an economy where
everyone gets a fair shot and everyone
does their fair share and everyone plays
by the same set of rules
it's not the case that inequality is
attributable to bad apples but rather
that the barrel is bad the barrel is
what's contaminating the apples it's the
institutions that prioritize getting
ahead above all else that it's okay to
break the law if that means that you're
going to make more profits for the
company with no attention to what the
consequences are for the system as a
whole
what I object to is the feeling that
there's some mechanism out there about
which you can do nothing at all that's
not simply not true humans want to
change this they can change it
[Music]
my name is Leah Taylor and I'm here
today to have a voice for my fellow
workers and everybody that's struggling
in the fast food industry Rochelle Monty
what would you like to say to the boss
of Allied Health for whom you work I
don't blame any one particular company
the truth is unless the government
actually acknowledged the importance of
the Home Care sector within this country
people are going to continue to be
filled these problems are deep rooted
within the system and it's the system
that needs to change my name is Janet
Sparks
and I am a Walmart associate at store
number 1102. when I think about the fact
that our CEO Mike Duke made over 20
million dollars last year more than 1
000 times the average Walmart associate
with all due respect
I have to say I don't think that's right
[Music]
[Applause]
I wish we'd never got into this state I
wish we'd never
had these extraordinary High Rewards I
didn't realize that that was going to
happen maybe others always knew
perfectly well that this would be the
result of it but I think that that is
unfortunate and I I regret it I think
you know you sort of always have it
maybe in the back of your mind that you
know you're not part of something good
but I didn't have a clear sense of I am
doing something actively harmful and
then when the financial crisis hit I
started to feel really uncomfortable and
I asked my boss will the public ever
forgive us for this and meaning the
bailout and he basically said to me well
here's the thing the public always
forgets the public forgot after the
Savings and Loan crisis the public
forgot after long-term Capital
Management blew up
the public always forgets and the public
will forget again and we will you know
move on and it'll go back to normal so
don't worry about it
[Music]
I've been sober for coming up for 11
months that's the longest I've ever been
away from a drink
and I've learned my margin for error is
very small
I mean if I pack up a drink I'm right
back to square one you know
I can't do it all by myself
[Music]
you got to help me baby
there's a push
to have a secondary gate
to keep these 10 to 20 homes completely
separate from the rest of the homes that
are already completely separate
I think it's a status thing more than a
fear thing
there's already a guy at the gate half
of them with a gun
[Music]
and to be honest I'd rather live in
Florida
one of my next motivating factors is
going to be the fact that I do want to
eventually move to Florida and have a
second home there
[Music]
I won't have any regrets I might be
living under a bridge next week you know
but
at least I I tried
If I Could Be A Millionaire or anything
like that and buy one big house they got
about 50 bedrooms you know and have all
my family with me
you know I would love that I would love
that
find myself somebody
always have enough to work so much
I wish I could see the kids a bit more
and I could go out for dinner at night I
don't want much out of life
I just wish
it was a bit easier
[Music]
most likely I'll end up back here
but it won't be because I'd walked into
a school and shot up a whole bunch of
children
or rape somebody or anything like that
it'll be because I probably got caught
stealing a loaf of bread and get a life
sentence for it
[Music]
oh yeah
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]